FOSSDA, the Free and Open Source
Stories Digital Archive
Foundation.
It's the 16th of April 2024 and I
am Elisabetta Mori, an historian
of computing currently based in
Italy and an oral history
interview with FOSSDA.
Today I'll be talking to Larry
Augustin.
Larry Augustin is an entrepreneur,
angel investor and advisor to
technology companies.
He He was the founder of VA
Research that became VA Linux,
SourceForge.
He was part of the team who who
coined the term Open Software.
He was CEO of SugarCRM and the
Vice President for Applications
and and Web Services.
We are recording on the story.io
and I am in Livorno, Tuscany,
Italy, and Larry is in his home in
Los Altos, California.
So thank you and welcome, Larry.
Thank you, Elisabetta.
Happy to be here.
Happy to do this.
Yeah, so let's start from the
beginning.
So where and when were you born?
Oh, I was born 1962 in Dayton,
Ohio, the middle of the country in
the US.
My father was in the Air Force and
we had settled in Dayton and ended
up growing up there.
My mother's side of the family
were farmers and had a farm in the
east coast of the US, New
Hampshire.
And I spent a lot of times there.
In fact, if you look at sort of my
early life, the time I spent in
summers working on the farm was
part of what helped me become an
engineer.
My dad was an electrical engineer
and so I sort of followed in his
footsteps.
That was my, you know, sort of
goal a whole life was to follow in
his footsteps and also be an
electrical engineer.
But I spent the summers working on
the family farm in New Hampshire,
you know, baling hay, doing, you
know, everything around the place.
And I developed this tendency to
just fix things.
It's part of what drove me to be
an engineer.
I often say, when you're out in
the field and the tractor breaks,
there's nobody to call.
You know, we didn't have cell
phones, there was no one there.
You had to just fix things
yourself.
And so my whole life, that's how I
kind of approach things, which is
just learn to do whatever needs to
be done and be hands-on and fix
things.
And what about your mom?
What did she do?
My mom is a nurse.
She grew up on the farm and then
she was able to go to nursing
school and she became a nurse.
And then, you know, after I came
along, she retired from that and
was a full-time mom.
And who were the important
influences on you in your early
life?
Oh, great question.
You know, obviously my parents.
I mean, I had just huge respects
there, wanting to follow in the
footsteps of my dad in many ways.
But early on in life, I would say
I was lucky to have great teachers
early in school, grade school and
elementary, who really, I guess,
influenced me in the value of
education, but in all sorts of
different disciplines, whether it
was mathematics or science.
And, you know, I was lucky to have
great teachers who helped me
there.
And, you know, some of that
certainly by random.
I was lucky.
And I was also lucky in that
Dayton, Ohio, is home to something
called the Ham Fest, which I don't
know if a lot of people know, but
it is a gathering of ham radio
operators that happens every year.
But beyond that sort of just ham
radio operators, it's really about
people who tinker with
electronics.
And so I was lucky to have this
exposure early on that this
interesting thing was happening
and I wanted to learn.
And so I was a kid who always was
experimenting with sort of basic
electronics.
I had the little kits as a kid
where you would build the radio
from scratch or you would wire
together a little electronic
circuits.
And I was always kind of tinkering
or doing or building something
like that.
Which schools did you attend?
And is there any, you know, an
event or episode that shaped you?
Oh, wow.
So, you know, I went through the
sort of public school system
growing up in Ohio.
I went to high school, a little
place called Stebbins High School.
I'm not sure I would say Stebbins
is famous for just about anything.
It was just a great place to grow
up and be a kid.
And from there, my mother had
always had this dream that I grew
up Catholic and my family was
Catholic and that her son should
go to the University of Notre
Dame.
And I applied.
And to be honest, to this day, I'm
not sure how I got in.
I was a good student, not the
best, but a good student.
And if I look today, you know, the
students that apply to
universities today are absolutely
amazing.
I don't know.
I was far from absolutely amazing.
And I got in.
So I ended up going to college at
Notre Dame.
And what was the subject?
Oh, that's where I followed my
dad's footsteps and I went into
electrical engineering.
And that's really where I sort of
spent my first time, sort of more
hands-on with computers.
There was one thing in my high
school that was interesting.
There was a course I took as I
began to try and understand
electronics and computers, but
more a course at this time.
And gosh, you look back and you
realize how far the world has
come.
That my first sort of exposure to
doing anything with programming
was punched cards with cobalt.
And as a high school student, I
was able to take a course where we
didn't even have a punch card
machine.
We had these big coding forms, big
ledger sheets of paper, 11 by 17
pieces of paper with lines on
them.
And there were 80 columns on a
punch card.
And you literally wrote in clean
print across these sheets of
paper.
And we would send them in.
So I'd have to write my program
out by hand on a piece of paper.
You'd send it in.
People would punch those into the
punch card machines.
You would get back decks of cards.
And then you sorted the cards into
a program.
And then you sent the cards in to
run.
So we think today about fast turn
and programming and developing
code.
The productivity in that sense of
lines of code was pretty low.
It was, you know, you spent a day
writing forms.
You sent it in.
You got punched cards back.
I mean, it took a week to turn
around.
And if you made one change, a
comma in a different place, one
different line, it was a week to
make a minor change.
So you had to get that right.
You had to make sure that was sort
of perfect when it went in because
the turnaround was very slow.
Then when I got to college, we
began to discover real
programmable machines,
microcontrollers.
At the time, there were new
machines like the TRS-80.
And eventually by the time I
graduated, the IBM PC and the
Apple machines had come out.
But that was my earliest exposure,
was writing COBOL programs, long
form.
So you go to Notre Dame, 1980,
1984.
And then in 1984, you get the
fellowship from Bell Labs to go.
Yes.
So Notre Dame was a great, great
place to me.
I had an opportunity to experience
a lot of different opportunities,
ranging from sort of those initial
exposures to real sort of
programmable machines,
microcontrollers, learning that.
I was lucky enough to be part of a
group that created the first
personal computer lab there for
the grant from IBM.
I was lucky enough to be able to
work on a, we took an IBM PC and
modified it to run IBM 370 code.
So IBM 370 being being the sort of
de facto standard of large scale
computing from the mainframe
world.
This was a time when there were
these two, I would say two worlds
of computing that were colliding.
The world of the, maybe that COBOL
world, if you will, big mainframe
machines, a slow turnaround,
hugely powerful, but you could see
the microprocessor world coming.
You know, we had the 8080, we had
the IBM PC.
And I was lucky enough to be part
of a project that re-micro-coded
the mineral to 68,000.
My part was working on a cache
memory system, and we built the
first IBM 370 inside a IBM PC.
So I had an opportunity to work on
some really, really great
computing things there.
And then following, as I graduated
there, Bell Labs had this
fantastic program where they would
recruit students out of college
with no experience.
And it's interesting, I
interesting, I watch today,
students coming out of college and
some of these programs don't exist
anymore.
I anymore.
I think we need more of those.
I think I was a beneficiary of
companies that did those things
when did those things when I
graduated.
They would recruit students out of
college and to work at Bell Labs
at the time, you had to have a
minimum of a master's degree.
I didn't have a master's degree,
but they also had identified that
there weren't enough people with
master's degrees.
And so they would recruit kids
right out of their undergraduate,
they would bring them in, they'd
give them an opportunity to work
for a year, and then they would
send them off to school to get
their master's, get advanced
degrees.
Fabulous, fabulous program.
I was lucky enough to get accepted
into that.
And I went from South Bend,
Indiana, Notre Dame, to Holmdel,
New Jersey, the home of the
transistor, and Bell Labs, the
place where the Big Bang was
discovered, and I got an
opportunity to just learn more.
And as part of that program, they
sent me to Stanford University to
get my master's degree in
electrical engineering.
Think heavily, though, computing.
Back then, computer science, by
the way, was kind of this...
When I went to Notre Dame, there
was not a computer science
department, put put it that way.
It was electrical engineering, and
computing was an offshoot.
So if you think about, in other
places, the, you know, computer
science being an offshoot of
mathematics, for example, those
were the years when those sorts of
departments were new, in some
sense, thinking of computing as a
separate thing.
But I was...
If you are a young, excited
engineer who loves building
things, and loves electronics, and
is excited about what you've been
able to do with computers, and you
get the opportunity to go to
Silicon Valley and Stanford in
1985, it's just a magical place,
and you stay.
So I spent a couple of years in
New Jersey with Bell Labs, Labs,
but ultimately, I was drawn back
to, you know, that world of
computing in the early years, in
the mid-80s, in Silicon Valley.
And after a year or two at Bell
Labs, I ended up back at Stanford
for my PhD. So in 1987, you moved
back to Stanford, and what was
your PhD about?
Electrical engineering.
And I've stayed in that, although,
I will say, at this point, getting
a lot harder to distinguish what I
was doing from computer science.
It was a lot less electrical, and
a lot more computer science.
I did blend the two together.
I worked on verifying, creating
ways to verify circuit designs.
At the time, the world of
electronic design automation was
new and exciting, and we were
developing software that helped
people build electronics.
There was this world that I spent
much of my time there called
hardware description languages,
HDLs.
That is a programming language for
describing circuits, circuit
design hardware.
And I worked on verifying timing
properties of circuits described
in hardware description languages.
And that's where I ultimately
developed my thesis on validating,
both through simulation and formal
logic, that a circuit held certain
timing properties.
And so, when did you get involved
with Linux?
What was it?
One of the things that we did in
those early days in electronic
design automation, most of the
work was done at universities.
So Stanford, we collaborated and
used a lot of tools of tools that
were written by the University of
California, Berkeley, UC Berkeley.
All of that software was available
for sharing on this thing, in
hindsight, the internet.
But the internet at the time was a
collection mostly of universities
and a few research labs that were
able to share and distribute
software.
And everything that I tended to
work with was software that was
available for free.
I mentioned earlier that I'm kind
of one of these people that just
dives in and sees things and wants
to fix things.
I had ended up, for my research
group at Stanford, doing a lot of
system administration work.
Just, again, administration work.
Just, again, I see things that
need to be done.
I have a tendency to just kind of
dive in and do it.
And I didn't of dive in and do it.
And I didn't know anything about
the things at the time.
I'd been lucky enough to spend my
time at Bell Labs, been lucky
enough to spend my time at Bell
Labs, where I had taken a few
courses in Unix, and I had the
opportunity to dive in and really
to dive in and really play with
some interesting Unix machines.
But out at Stanford, we used, at
the time, Sun workstations for
most of our work.
And whenever out at Stanford, we
used, at the time, Sun
workstations for most of our work.
And whenever we'd get a Sun
workstation, one of the things
that I would help with and did was
to take that machine and install
all the software that we used to
do our research.
Primarily electronic design
automation tools.
Many of, as I said, were developed
and just given away for free by
other universities.
I recall carrying around with me
at the time was a, you know, a
hard disk drive.
And now we would look at it as
kind of a little tiny USB thumb
drive.
But, you know, when I carried it
around, it was big and I would
plug that in and, and essentially
upload all of this free software
onto this commercial machine.
And it was because, it wasn't
because we couldn't afford or get
any software we wanted.
As a research team at Stanford, we
had access to to essentially
anything we wanted to access to
commercially.
We could get that.
But the software that we used was
easier to work with, was better,
was available for free.
And that's where I really learned
that, that, uh, a community of
people working together with the
goal of producing great software
was often producing things that
were better than what was
available commercially.
And so that's where I began to
learn that I could see that
difference from early on.
For example, early on, we did much
of our work in C. And the Sun
machine always came with the C And
the Sun machine always came with
the C compiler.
C compiler was part of Unix.
But Richard Stallman over at the
Free Software Foundation at MIT
had started building a C compiler,
GNU C, which was vastly superior
to what came with the machines
commercially.
And so we would install it and use
that.
And again, lucky enough to be at
Stanford, the gentleman in the
office across the hall from me,
Michael Tiemann, was one of the
core contributors to GNU C, in
particular C++.
And we were lucky enough to be
able to sort of see that evolve
and develop quickly and be
superior to what was available
commercially.
And so that's where I really
learned that difference.
From early on, though, all that
work was done on these powerful
Sun workstations, which were
expensive.
And I had this dream of being able
to use Unix and work from home.
That would have been fantastic.
So I began looking around at ways
to do that.
And it turns out there were
several people that had begun
releasing variants of Unix that
ran on the IBM PC.
You're sort of at the time where
the Intel processors had reached
the point with the release of the
386, where the processor was
powerful enough to run a real Unix
virtual machine.
And code from a variety of
sources, it was the core of Unix,
had begun to be available.
And I had played around with some
other things.
There were some Unix variants that
were commercially available, but
to be honest, they were slow and
clunky.
So I began trying ones off the
internet, as I did with any
software.
And I compared two systems at the
time.
So one was releases of the
Berkeley Unix system, VSD, that
had been released for PC for the
386.
And the other was the system that
this student in Finland, Linus
Tormalds, had begun to put
together, and that various people
had bundled up systems around it.
And I remember downloading and
installing my first version of
Linux Slackware.
I want to say it took 40 to 50,
1.44 megabyte floppy disks to copy
and install a Linux distribution
at the time.
And in hindsight, looking back, it
wasn't a very big system, but we
weren't running around with a lot
of storage in space either.
And managing your collection of
floppy disks was part of the
challenge.
But it was interesting.
I had enough computer science
background.
I had done in-depth operating
system understanding and work that
I understood that the architecture
of the Berkeley system was, I
don't know if the right word is
maybe a little bit cleaner, maybe
a little bit more formal, a little
bit more mature.
However, Linus's system was
evolving much faster.
And I played with both systems.
The Linux machine was super fast.
And I looked at the, at the time,
Usenet newsgroups was a big part
of how people communicated.
I looked at the traffic and usage
and the pace of development.
And I said, you know, there are
more sophisticated operating
system features that the Berkeley
Unix has that Linux does not have
today.
But the pace of development, this
path is going to cross.
And so I built a home workstation
running on a 386 PC running Linux
and brought all of my software
over that I used that I had gotten
off the internet and was now able
to pursue my research working from
home.
Other people saw what I had put
together.
I said, that is, that is really
cool.
I want one of those too.
A business is born.
I want I want to say this was, at
this point, we have reached the
early 90s.
I think around 93 was when I
looked at this and said, this was
shortly after I had finished my
PhD, I defended my thesis.
I was working as a research staff
at Stanford.
And I realized I could have, as
one person characterized it to me
as a lemonade stand as a kid.
But I started a side business of
selling people pre-configured
Linux workstations.
And I went from sort of friends
and family to, there was this new
thing that had developed on the
internet called the World Wide
Web.
You could create, there was a new
called the World Wide Web.
brand new thing called a web
browser.
You could create a visual UI.
By the way, this is all pre-CSS.
Pre-JavaScript.
You had HTML with some basic
structuring tags.
And I put up a web page.
A web page, a web page offering
Linux workstations.
And it was kind of odd.
At this time, as I said, the web
was new.
Intel had discovered the web and
Intel had a website.
And on their website, they listed
other companies.
web and Intel had a website.
And on their website, they listed
other companies.
They listed companies selling
Intel-based computers.
And I think they had five
companies listed.
companies selling Intel-based
computers.
And I think they had five
companies listed on the Intel
website that were selling Intel
computers, Intel-based computers
on the internet.
They were Dell, Compaq, Gateway,
and me.
And I think there was one other.
I'm not sure who the other was.
And talk about a surprise.
Where does that come from?
But I was in some excellent
company.
What was the name of the website?
So that was VA Research.
Okay.
So that is when VA Research was
born.
That's when VA Research was born.
And what's the name?
VA?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
So I had started doing this with
my co-worker and friend, James
Vera.
And so we were trying to figure
out what do we call this as we put
it up there.
And James and I were having this
conversation.
And we were inspired by Hewlett
and Packard in the garage in
Silicon Valley.
So we had Vera and Augustin.
But in hindsight, probably a
terrible name.
Everyone thinks the company was
from Virginia.
It was VA, the abbreviation.
But that's what we ended up with.
That's what we ended up with.
And so we launched that business,
I want to say around 93, we began
doing this.
People would send us a check.
This is just an amazing way of
bootstrapping.
And to me, I always look for
today, I love the entrepreneurial
part of the world and people
launching and building things.
And we got people to send us
checks for the computers they
wanted, because we were selling a
physical device.
And to me, these things were
hugely expensive.
I mean, somewhere between $1,000
and $3,000.
And I couldn't afford to buy the
parts to send someone.
Well, a system that had been put
together.
People sent us a check ahead of
time.
We would cash the check, go buy
the parts, have an assembly party
in the living room of my apartment
and ship them out.
And that was what the business was
initially.
And then sometimes we would get a
little more sophisticated.
We'd run up the bill on our credit
cards and get a little bit of a
better deal on parts sometime, be
willing to buy ahead a little bit.
But that's how we funded the
business.
That's the business.
That's how we funded the business.
I had been doing some consulting
work for a company in the EDA
space and struck a deal where I
was able to work out of that
space.
In Menlo Park and struck a deal
there and began working that sort
of more full time.
So how did the company evolve?
And so we went through.
So I eventually decided I am
spending more time on this side
hobby than I am doing my research
job at Stanford.
So I decided it was time to dive
in and do that a full time.
I was also inspired here by the
fact that it's kind of what you do
around a place like Silicon Valley
and Stanford.
You see other people doing this
and you see people diving into
this full time.
So I dove into it full time.
I looked for help there.
At one point, I had found a
company I was partnering with
called Umax, a Taiwanese company.
We worked out of Umax for a little
while.
Just whatever we could do to sort
of fund and keep the business
around.
As I said, people would send us
checks to fund the business.
I got my first office, a little
place called Pear Avenue in
Mountain View.
Coincidentally, now the Microsoft
Silicon Valley building is where
my office was in Mountain View
with VA Linux.
There was a, again, I have no
idea, I have no idea sometimes why
these things happen, but I was
lucky enough to find office space.
To be honest, I don't know why
they were willing to sign a lease
with a kid who was barely breaking
even.
I think it was a rental
foreclosure and I got an office
and fired up the business for
real.
We ran hand to mouth, was the
business.
Literally, a big part of the job
was how do you juggle checks
coming in from customers so that
you could buy the parts to create
the systems to send to those
customers, balancing that.
At the same time, I was very
active with the Linux groups on
the internet, staying close to
that, watching the development of
that, because all the software we
used was software that was coming
off the internet for free.
I really had this vision, if you
will.
Dell had been very inspirational
to me.
If you look at the start of Dell
Computers with Michael Dell and
his dorm room at, I think it was
UT Austin, assembling PCs.
I was doing the same, except I was
doing it in the Unix world.
If you look, Dell is effectively a
logistics company in many ways.
That is, they bring together a lot
of components to create what they
create.
We were doing the same, bringing
together components to assemble
the hardware, but we were doing a
similar thing on the software
side.
I thought of what we were doing as
extending the Dell model from not
just Dell for hardware, but Dell
for software.
That is, we are going to assemble,
package, configure, maintain,
support the software side in a
similar model.
Our supply chain for software was
the internet.
At the time, it was all called
free software.
The business became about bringing
the two of those together to
create a traditional Unix
workstation business in the line
of Sun, but where the hardware was
open Intel technology hardware,
where we could bring together
components from a variety of
places.
The software was open free
software, where we could bring
together software from a variety
of places.
The combination of that was really
the vision and view of, at the
time, VA research.
We decided research was in the
wrong connotation and Linux was
beginning to get some reference
and brand name, and it became VA
Linux.
As I was doing this, two of my
friends from Stanford had raised
venture funding.
Two gentlemen by the name of Jerry
Yang and David Filo.
You may recall those names as
their little company they had
started was Yahoo.
Dave and Jerry were both PhD
students in EDA, Electronic Design
Automation, at Stanford.
They had started this little
directory of the web on a machine
under their desk in their office
at Stanford.
And Dave, Jerry, and I, and there
was a fourth person, David Koo,
had been considering ways that we
could turn the things we were
doing into businesses.
We looked at the internet.
We considered various ways you
could turn the internet into
commerce, create a business.
At the same time, I was doing this
Linux workstation idea.
They were playing with this
directory of the internet, and
they had gotten Sequoia Capital to
fund that.
They said one day, said, Larry,
you ought to meet the guys up at
Sequoia, gentlemen by the name of
Doug Leone, and see if there's a
way you could take capital and
grow what you're doing.
I said, well, that sounds like a
great idea.
We've been living hand to mouth,
trying to build this business, and
all along trying to do interesting
things with the growth of Linux
and development through software.
They introduced me to Doug Leone
over at Sequoia Capital.
I went up to Sequoia, had my first
pitch.
In hindsight, I have no idea why
Doug continued to talk to me.
He knew more about entrepreneurs
than I knew about anything.
And it was a fantastic first
conversation, but all of their
checks said, oh, this Linux stuff,
I don't know.
It's kind of a toy.
We really like you, Larry, but
we're not ready to invest
something there.
And I said, that's fine.
I didn't know anybody else.
I knew nothing about venture
capital.
I really had no idea what I was
doing.
But every few months, I would send
Doug an email update with how the
business was going and what was
happening in the world of Linux.
And it was interesting because
Doug is an incredibly smart
gentleman.
And he did a little bit of the
same things when I looked at
Berkeley Unix versus Linux.
I ultimately made the decision
that the acceleration path of
Linux is higher.
Doug had done certain kind of
asking and questions around.
And he had kept hearing, no, Linux
is kind of a toy.
But he was watching things
develop.
And I kept sending him updates.
And Forbes magazine had figured
this out.
And they put Linus Torvalds on the
cover.
And it was kind of a pivotal
moment.
I had sent this to Doug.
And Doug, and by the way, this was
also shortly after Red Hat
Software and Bob Young had gotten
funded.
Eric Trone, Bob Young, that whole
team, great, great people had
gotten funded.
And Sequoia looked over.
And I think it was literally
something to the phrase of, Larry,
we don't quite know what's going
on here, but we need to do
something in this Linux space
because something is happening
there.
And you're the only guy we know.
Which, if you know Doug, is just a
fantastic endorsement, if you
will.
Incredible person.
And they showed up.
And I took the first outside
investment.
And at the same time, I was really
about advancing the state of the
world of free software and what
you could and what you could do
with Linux.
I had been tracking down contacts
at Intel for years.
And Intel felt something was going
on there as well.
So Intel joined the Series A to
invest in us with the idea that
this could be a part of the market
in which they were not a major
player, but now they could begin
to move into the server
workstation world with Unix and
Linux.
And so that effectively moved us
from a small business to, okay,
now how do we build a big
business?
That was a big step.
I would be remiss to not point out
just, again, how lucky we were to
be in the right place at the right
time with people around Silicon
Valley and the community of people
that was building the software.
I hired a gentleman, Leonard
Zubkoff, as our CTO, who was one
of the...
Leonard ultimately did the first
multiprocessor kernel work
developing Linux.
He did significant work on other
parts of the system.
We were always contributing back
or looking for ways to be part of
the help of that community.
At one time, interestingly, much
of the software that we developed
was built by Richard Stallman's
Free Software Foundation.
At one time, the machine that was,
Richard Stallman's Free Software
Foundation.
At one time, the machine that was,
in fact, the machine on the
internet distributing that
software on the internet
distributing that software sat in
the back of our office.
It was a MIT.edu internet address,
but the actual server was in the
back of our office because we
donated that that to the Free
Software Foundation to distribute
software.
And you think today about the
cloud.
In the late 90s, the cloud was a
smaller machine with just a lot of
disk drives sitting under
somebody's desk in the back of an
office in Mount V, if you will.
And that was common in those days.
So that began sort of the launch
of how do we turn this into a
larger business.
So what year was this when you
finally...
Uh, that was probably 1997.
And we grew the business very
rapidly from that point.
We went public in 99.
So it was at most two years from
first funding to IPO.
And the world of Linux was just on
fire then.
I remember just on fire then.
I remember we helped organize some
of the first large-scale Linux
events in Silicon Valley.
At some point, you don't quite
realize the scale of the internet
at the time, nowhere near what it
is today.
And it wasn't always obvious how
many people were out there.
You could watch traffic on Usenet
groups.
We could traffic on Usenet groups.
We could share code and contribute
to the community.
And we were the first large
traffic on Usenet groups.
We could share code and
contribute.
But you didn't always quite
realize the scale.
And we organized an event in
Silicon Valley called the Future
of Linux, where I was able to get
people from Intel and from
different groups.
Companies like Cisco would just
give us the space because they
wanted to support local user
groups.
And we ran this event.
We called it the Future of Linux.
It was the first...
I'll say prior to that, the Linux
user group meeting was a dozen
people in a fast food restaurant
in Silicon Valley.
But we promoted this.
And we had over a thousand people
show up, standing room only.
We completely overwhelmed the
conference facilities that we had
been able to beg, borrow, and get
donated.
And again, that was another point
at which people like Sequoia
Capital began to realize there's
some momentum here.
And the scale is bigger than you
may realize.
I think a lot of people point to
that event as a turning point.
And I'll say the recognition by
many people around Silicon Valley
and that ecosystem that there was
something here.
I think it would be pretentious
for anyone to say we knew what it
was in that sense.
But just the number of people that
would come together, it was
fantastic.
So there was an event like that.
As this was developing, more and
more of us were I think struggling
a little bit with a divide in the
community between why we were
building software in an open model
like this on the internet.
If you listen to my story, I was
using software that was freely
available because it was better.
To me, that was always the model.
I used the GNU C compiler because
it was better than the C compilers
that came from Sun. The same was
similar for user interface tools.
Linux was a free operating system.
There were commercial Unix systems
that were available, but the fact
is Linux were available, but the
fact is Linux is better for the PC
than the commercial systems.
And that had always been my
philosophy.
This is a philosophy that's very
different from the Free Software
Foundation and Richard Stallman's
motivation.
It had been very, you know, driven
by the notion that software is
something that should be freely
available to everyone.
And he had developed the GNU model
and the GNU licensing model that
was designed to encourage that.
But this split was developing and
was, I think, licensing model that
was designed to encourage that.
But this split was developing and
was, I think, exacerbated by
groups of us that had been
building businesses around free
software.
And if you look at the concept of
I am selling you something that's
free, it's kind of an odd concept.
It takes people a moment to get
their heads around this concept.
And the people a moment to get
And the gentleman by the name of
Eric Raymond, just a great thought
leader, Eric is, had written a
paper called The Cathedral and the
Bazaar, where Eric described this
idea of software built in an open
model, in an open way where
everyone could see what was
happening, versus software built
in a closed way.
And he had written a paper called
The Cathedral and the Bazaar,
where Eric described this idea of
software built in a closed, you
know, in his world, the cathedral
this idea of software built in a
closed, you know, in his world,
the cathedral model.
And this really resonated with me,
because I think Eric had finally
captured what many of us had been
thinking or trying to understand.
But as Eric is, he's just sort of
brilliant at coalescing ideas.
He had written it down well and
articulated it well.
And some of it came together for
me.
I'll tell you a very small
anecdote here.
When I was building VA Research
and then VA Linux, we were using,
I had chosen QuickBooks as our
accounting software.
At the time, QuickBooks was very
new, but still small business
accounting software, you have to
have something.
I had chosen QuickBooks.
I had found a bug in QuickBooks.
And for the old time DOS
programmers and geeks, this bug
was the system would crash when I
would try and print.
And this happened because, this
happened whenever I tried to print
to a network attached printer.
And it turns out that network
printers could have names longer
than 11 characters.
And experimenting with this crash,
I discovered that if the name of
the printer was 11 characters
left, everything worked.
And if it was longer than 11
characters, it crashed.
And if you are a developer, you
could see what was happening.
There was a buffer of 11
characters, which by the way, is
exactly the same number of
characters of a file name in DOS,
which is where it came from.
And printers were attached to file
names.
So without being too technical
here, someone had a piece of code
that had an 11 character buffer
for the name.
And when it was longer than 11
characters, it ran off the end of
this and it crashed the program.
I could it crashed the program.
I could see this in my head.
And I know this is not necessarily
a mission critical story, but I
critical story, but I called up
into it.
I called up tech support.
I thought to myself, this is
great.
I can contribute can contribute
and tell them what to look for.
I could not get any attention.
I could not get anyone to care.
I could crash their software very
easily.
And I could imagine the fix in my
head as a programmer, and I could
not get anyone to care.
And all I could think was, if I
had the source code, I could fix
this.
Now, to me, that little experience
really crystallized what we had
been doing and what people like
Eric had begun to write about,
which is this notion that you
empower the person, the user, with
access.
You enable them.
Whether I could have fixed that
code in my case, you know, I like
to think I could have fixed the
code.
But if I had had access, maybe I
could have hired someone to fix
the code.
Or if it had been open, I could
have contributed a fix.
But none of that was possible
because the software was built in
a cathedral, and it was built in a
black box, and it was hidden, and
there was nothing you could do
about that.
And ultimately, Eric's book had
gotten the attention of Netscape
Software and Mark Andreessen at
the time, and they had invited
Eric to come out to Silicon
Valley, and I hosted Eric for a
bit when he came out.
He came by the office, and I don't
think we had ever met face-to-face
before that.
It's interesting, you know, many
of these relationships all
developed online.
And we convened a meeting at our
offices in Mountain View where we
were discussing this, and Eric was
driving the idea that we should
rebrand.
We should push the, we need to
emphasize the notion that what we
care about is creating great
software.
We're not making a religious
statement.
We're not making a political
We are simply saying we want to
create great software, and we have
discovered a model that we believe
creates better software.
Maybe not in all cases, but
certainly from our observation, in
a lot of cases.
And we need to emphasize that.
And so, we held a meeting at my
office in Pear Avenue.
We got Linus on the phone, and
ultimately, the idea was we're
going to brand this open source,
because the openness of the source
code was what was important.
We're going to Bruce Perens, at
the time, the head of the Debian
project, had created a set of
definitions for software that
could be part of Debian.
And we realized the world here
needed to separate the notion
notion of software in which the
source code is available from free
software, and we coined the term
open source to do that.
And we all agreed to promote and
develop this, and that became the
genesis for the term open source.
And this was in 1998?
I think it was 1998.
I will tell you I'm not as good
with the years and the dates as I
should be, so I encourage anyone
listening to this to just go to
the opensource.org website, and
it's well documented there, and
they have made sure the dates are
correct.
How's that?
Yeah.
So, during these years, I would
like to ask you a couple of
things.
Two things are personal.
Yes.
First, when was your first
encounter with Linus Torvalds?
Oh, you know, excellent question.
I don't have a great recollection
of the first meeting.
I'm sure I was so in awe that I
just was probably standing
stunned.
I believe it was in the back of a
fast food restaurant at a local
Linux user group after he had
moved.
You know, many of this happened
remotely, and then Linus moved to
Silicon Valley in the Bay Area,
and I believe it was the back of a
fast food restaurant at a small
Linux user group meeting.
I was always in awe of just
fantastic talent that came into
this community.
When it comes to coding and
development, I'm more of a
sysadmin hack.
I get some of these things, and I
can pull things together and such,
but the ability of people like
Linus, my CTO and VA gentleman,
and the talent that comes together
is just incredible, and the depth
is incredible there.
So, we had small Linux user group
meetings around the Valley, and
then I was eventually sort of able
to develop a friendship there and
pull Linus into some of those
events like that Future of Linux
event that I talked about.
Okay.
So, we're going to just talk
briefly about your personal life.
So, when did you get married and
when your daughter was born?
Oh, wow.
Okay.
So, yes, during this, I had met my
wife at Stanford, Alice, and we
were married in, I want to say,
96, and our daughter was born a
year later, Andrea, and Alice had
joined me at VA Research in the
early days and was our first
salesperson.
So, the success of the business,
very much driven by her on the
phone with customers, talking with
customers and helping us create
business.
You met at Stanford, what was she
studying or researching?
So, she had gone to San Francisco
State and was working in a staff
position at Stanford in our
research lab, what we've had.
Okay.
So, we are like 1997, 1998.
Yes.
Then we arrived to 1999, which is
important.
The end of 1999 is important for
two reasons.
One is SourceForge, we're talking
about number 1999, and the second
one is VA Linux.
But if you remember, it's not
important, when did you change the
name from VA Research to VA Linux,
if you remember?
I don't remember exactly the date,
but it was the, part of it was
the, it may have been in part the
funding.
And then as we were thinking about
branding coming into the IPO, the
term research, just people didn't
quite understand what we did.
So, we put Linux in the name.
So, yes.
So, the two main things that
happened in 1999, the end of 1999,
November, SourceForge and
September IPO.
Yeah.
SourceForge, let me tell you a
little bit about SourceForge.
So, I mentioned before that we
would do things such as host a
machine for the Free Software
Foundation.
And my vision of a software supply
chain, if you will, where the
software created for free on the
internet, openly on the internet,
was our supply chain that we would
build together into systems.
I wanted to enable that.
And we wanted to create and enable
more people to do that and make it
easier.
So, we regularly hosted websites
and software distribution FTP
sites for free free software, open
source, now open source projects.
That was common.
At one point, we were, I believe,
hosting upwards of 20 major
projects like this.
And we observed that the people
running these projects all had a
set of common needs.
You know, they wanted a website,
but they wanted FTP distribution,
and they wanted a mailing list.
Sometimes they wanted discussion
forums.
They wanted to host FAQs.
There was a new, I would say,
somewhat new concept that was
becoming more common among the
groups, which was source code
repositories.
Now people just, you know, GitHub.
And we didn't have Git at the
time.
We had a few different revision
control systems, but most free
software was not built revision
control, but people were starting
to say, well, gee, you don't want
to have a CDS or similar revision
control system site.
Well, at the same time, there was
a project underway to recreate the
history of Linux, the history of
the Linux source code.
Again, most people at the time
starting out with a project didn't
start out with revision control.
Now it's just a given.
You just do it.
And Linux had never done revision
control.
He released, you know, he would
release a new version of Linux a
new version of Linux out on the
internet, and he didn't
necessarily keep old versions.
That's, That's, you know, I
released it on the internet.
I moved on, create a new version.
And so, new version.
And so, I was observing that we
were at a, we were at risk of
losing information that could
become important to us as we built
software.
Another personal anecdote, I had
discovered at this time a bug in a
piece of software on the Linux
system, the bash shell, which is
the command line interpreter.
And I went to look for the source
code to see if I could fix the
bug, and actually couldn't find
the source code.
Because the version I was running
was two releases behind, and none
of the distribution sites kept the
old releases.
So, kind of all of these things
were coming together at the same
time.
So, I did a little math
calculation.
And at the time, it's a pretty
good ability to look and
understand how much source code
was released, open source and free
software on the internet every
year.
And I realized, if you took all of
that code and you kept it
permanently, it almost tracked to
the size of a large disk drive
that you could buy at a very
modest price.
And so, I realized, there's no,
there's not, you don't need to
delete anything ever again for
source code.
So, I wanted to begin to archive
the history of source code.
And we had acquired at VA Linux,
we had begun to acquire a set of
internet sites that supported free
software and similar development.
And one of those sites was a site
called Fresh Meat.
Odd name, but Fresh Meat was the
de facto announcement site at the
time.
So, all free software, that open
source software that was released,
was announced on Fresh Meat.
And I came up with this vision,
which was, we need to archive all
of that.
So, my vision was to connect Fresh
Meat to an archive site, and I
called it cold storage.
So, the idea was to put all Fresh
Meat in cold storage and keep it
forever.
Because we did not want to lose
our history, we wanted to
understand how and why things had
been built.
So, I began this archive project.
And the team at VA Linux that I
gave this job to, actually,
actually, it was kind of a side
project, if you will, for them,
was also the team that, in IT,
that was hosting, helping projects
host and build these internet
sites.
But if you go back, we famously,
we love doing t-shirts for
everything.
It's a developer Silicon Valley
thing, I guess.
But I have these famously, these
cold storage t-shirts, we launched
this project.
And that team looked at that idea,
and they said, well, that's nice,
Larry, but we spend a lot of our
time helping people build these
sites.
So, we want to bring those ideas
together.
And they brought those ideas
together and ultimately turned
that into, let's not just store an
archive, but let's make it easy
for people to build and launch.
Cold storage turned out to be a
difficult internet name, and they
came up with SourceForge.
And we launched SourceForge as the
first collaborative development
system for devs on the internet.
And our ideas, we wanted to enable
everybody.
If you wanted to build an open
source project, we wanted to give
you the infrastructure to do it.
We had even solicited Intel to
provide servers to sit behind this
so that people could compile and
build on the back end.
We had a great vision there.
And so, we were very excited to be
able to able to offer that to the
community when we launched it.
That's a little bit of the history
behind SourceForge.
And then on the 9th of December,
1999, there was the IPO.
Yes, yes.
Our business, so the original
business around VA Linux had been
built around the sort of Sun
workstation concept.
As the internet had grown, Linux
and open source software were
becoming the de facto software to
use to build the internet.
That placed us at a key junction
point in the development of
internet technology.
And our business had become all
about making high performance,
easy to use systems at a
reasonable cost available to
people who wanted to build out and
host internet sites.
That had become the most
significant part of the market.
And it was growing rapidly,
rapidly at the time.
And that led us to grow a very
significant business.
We were doing about 60 million in
revenue at the time.
And we decided to go public.
Today, you'd wait a little bit
longer, I think.
But then, there were smaller
public companies.
And public companies.
And we were right at the forefront
of that.
So, we set out to define that as
the business.
And we went public December 1999.
that as the business.
And ultimately, that became the
largest first day gain ever in an
IPO.
We priced the IPO, and I believe
it was $30 a share.
And the first opening trade was at
$299 a share, as there was just
huge demand.
As part of that, we also did what
I think was also the first ever
large-scale community involvement
in an IPO.
There was a concept that I began
developing.
I had hired a team of people at VA
Linux to do what we call community
marketing.
This is outreach to Linux users
groups, outreach to developers,
people working on the Linux
kernel.
And we assembled a list of core
contributors to Linux and open
source.
And we included them in the IPO,
gave them the opportunity to get
in.
And hopefully, let them make some
money for all their hard-earned
work off of that.
And to this day, I still get
people from those days telling me
that that made a difference for
them, which is just hugely
gratifying for me.
But we did this in a large scale.
And the bankers, to be honest, at
first, weren't really quite sure
how to do this.
So we had to come up with a lot of
ideas.
And the banking team had to be
invented in order for us to have
several thousand people from all
over the world participate, many
of whom were just their name was
in the Linux kernel.
And they were a contributor.
And we wanted to try and help them
or reward them.
So we wanted to try and help them
So we did that.
How many people were employed by
you at the time?
I want to say at the IPO time, the
company was still relatively
small.
I will say 250 people, ultimately
ultimately growing to about 800
people over the course of the next
two years.
And in 2000, Word Magazine named
you to their list of the top 50
CEOs.
Yes, yes, yes.
You know, learning on the job was
a lot of that.
I just had some fantastic people
around people around me and
fantastic investors in Sequoia
Capital.
And I was able to get a lot of
people involved.
And fantastic investors in Sequoia
Capital, fantastic mentors who
helped the company and joined
around the board from people like
Doug Leonio at Sequoia.
Carol Bartz was a great mentor for
me on the board.
Carol had run marketing at Sun.
And at the time, she sat on our
board.
I believe she was the CEO of
Autodesk.
Later, interestingly, to sort of
bring some things full circle, she
became the CEO of Yahoo for a
while.
But just, you know, fantastic,
fantastic people all around.
So what happened between the 2000
and the year 2002 when you left?
Yes.
So, so our business had been
heavily defined by companies, the
dot com world at that time.
And and And and the business was
growing very, very rapidly.
And that was all going well until
the dot com crash, if you will.
The the companies that we were
selling to were a who's who of dot
coms.
You know, companies like Pets.com
come up as a sort of poster child
here.
But over the course of about six
months, many of our customers
either went out of business or out
of business or just stopped,
stopped by.
And it was a big crash for us in
that space.
And ultimately, we restructured
the company to focus around
SourceForge and the software
business and less about Internet
servers.
And we did we did many innovative
things in the Internet Service
Society.
We built the first high density
rack mount servers that went into
data centers.
We did that to run the dot coms.
But ultimately, when that part of
the market crashed, it became very
difficult for us to maintain that
business.
So we started restructuring the
business, ultimately had to
downsize, went through a very,
very painful time where we had to
we had to lay off groups of people
to get there.
And we emerged as a smaller
company, more software focused,
focused around SourceForge.
And I'm very proud that we were
able to sort of survive through
that crash and downturn.
But for me, it was a different
business.
And when I got it to that point,
it was no longer as interesting or
exciting for me.
And it was time for me to go on
and do something different.
And what did you do in 2002?
So at that point, looking for
looking for kind of the next phase
of my career, some friends of mine
had joined, had created, had
founded a venture capital firm up
in San Francisco called Azure
Capital.
I loved, I loved the entrepreneur
stage.
I loved everything I'd learned
there.
And I had met many great people
who were launching businesses.
And many people told me that the
VA Linux IPO had been very
inspirational to them,
particularly coming out of the
open source software world with
the idea that that you could
create something here, you could
create something potentially world
changing.
And so I I joined my friends up at
Azure Capital and began to learn
the venture capital side of the
business.
And I wanted to take my
experiences and share them and
help others that were looking to
do that.
And so I spent a few years up at
Azure Capital, ultimately decided,
it's a fantastic firm, I love, I
love those guys.
And they're all great friends.
Today, to this day, ultimately
decided that I really wanted to do
it on my own, in the sense that I
wanted to back and follow
entrepreneurs that I wanted to
spend time with, it didn't
necessarily make sense for a firm
to be investing in.
So I spent I wanted to spend time
with, it didn't necessarily make
sense for a firm to be investing
in.
So I spent a few years at Azure
Capital.
And then I spent a few years on my
own, angel investing, and helping
early stage companies.
Again, just early stage companies,
again, just lucky enough to be
involved with some fantastic
entrepreneurs.
Early on, people like Mark Fleury,
who was the founder of JBoss, I
sat on that board, and companies
like Zensource, Spring, and
Pentaho, Richard Daly over there
built a incredible company around
open source business intelligence.
And I was lucky enough to be
involved with many great open
source primarily, businesses and
entrepreneurs.
Learned a ton.
It's one of the things that I
always, I was like doing things in
my career where I learned new
things.
Going into venture capital was
learning a new thing.
Doing it on my own was learning a
new thing.
Every one of these companies, I
learned tremendously from every
one of those great entrepreneurs
and CEOs.
And along the way, I had been
invited to come help out as an
independent board member, and
advisor to an open source company
in the CRM space, SugarCRM.
And so I joined the board over at
SugarCRM and put a little money as
an investor, and had spent several
years on the board there.
And there was a theme I was
developing, which was that open
source was moving up the software
stack.
Now there's the famous quote that
software eats the world, and open
source eats all software, if you
will.
Right?
I did not coin those phrases, but
very true.
And I had spent more time moving
up and learning business
applications.
Ultimately, the investors over at
SugarCRM said, Larry, we need to
figure out what to do with this
business.
We've been kind of stalled.
Would you take a look at it?
You're the operating person here.
You've run the business.
You know open source.
You don't know CRM, but will you
take a look?
And I ultimately spent 10 years in
that company.
Grew it into, in many ways, I
think a very influential company
for the open source world in the
CRM space.
We had fantastic customers, such
as IBM and Apple, SugarCRM
customers, and grew that business
for many years before selling into
a private equity firm, XLKKR.
Fantastic experience.
Great, great team.
I was lucky enough to be able to
write off of the efforts of
founders there, such as Quintor.
Just incredible team.
Okay, so you became CEO in 2009?
Yes.
And you left in 2019?
Yes, yes.
What did you do in 2019?
Yes, so after we sold the company
to XLKKR, I left SugarCRM.
I got a call from Amazon, an
interest in developing and
building more of the software that
was moving up the stack on AWS.
Amazon had built a set of
products, particular things like
their Connect call center product,
their WorkDocs file management
product, messaging and
communications, video
conferencing, and chat.
And they were trying to figure out
what to do with these products,
and they put them together into a
group.
And we're looking for someone to
help grow and develop that and
understand where to go with those
applications on AWS.
And if you are an entrepreneur,
and you've been building in the
mid to late 2000s, you're probably
building on AWS.
One of the things we had done at
SugarCRM was move to AWS for many
of our services.
And this was a common theme.
So I went over to AWS and was
lucky enough to be able to run
some very significant businesses
there for a couple of years and
help build those out.
It was fantastic.
I enjoyed it.
It's it.
It's a little bit of a different
experience.
Again, I wanted to learn.
If you look at my career, I've
made decisions all along the way
to do things that I've never done
before, because I want to learn
and I want to understand, the way
to do things that I've never done
before, because I want to learn
and I want to understand, and I
want to stretch myself.
And I'm never afraid to try things
that I don't know how to do.
I had a great experience over at
AWS for that.
Ultimately, I decided had a great
experience over at AWS for that.
Ultimately, I decided that I
wasn't going to stay in that big
company for a long time and went
back to being an angel investor
and advising and working with
early stage companies.
And that's what I'm doing today.
So did you move to Seattle when
you... I did not move to Seattle.
I did Seattle part-time.
So I had just the schedule that
was every other week.
So I'm a firm believer, just
philosophically, that you have to
be near the team and the people.
And so I got an apartment in
Seattle, and I went to Seattle
every other week and spend time
there.
I also, by the way, had teams in
the Bay Area.
So I had offices in San Francisco
and Seattle, and I had teams in
Silicon Valley, San Francisco,
Seattle, and around Washington, as
well as around the country,
working for me at AWS.
And so I would go back and forth.
So now that you're only focused on
being an angel investor, what is
your angel investment strategy?
So, or let me rephrase, how did
your strategy evolve from the
beginning?
And if it at all changed, if it
evolved from the beginning?
Sure, sure, sure.
It's interesting watching the
history of open source and
commercial companies, because it's
gone through some cycles.
Where it was very popular, less
popular.
Now, it's very popular, and it's
very common.
And I think many people realize
that you can build a great,
significant business around and
related to and using open source
technologies.
And to the point where you'll see
many companies that talk about
proprietary software, and
investors will look at them and
actually ask the question, should
you be doing some of this open
source?
So I don't mind open source,
obviously.
I've always felt one could build a
great business around it.
I've always felt that companies
have been too protective of their
source code.
But in fact, the value is in the
people and the culture and
everything you've built around
that, and and not necessarily in
just access to the code.
So I do a lot of open source.
It's a long way of saying I do a
lot of investing around open
source, because I think it's a
great, great incubator for great
technologies.
I love helping entrepreneurs that
are first time entrepreneurs, that
are trying to understand how to go
through the process.
I love seeing interesting
technologies.
I've been lucky enough to be at
the forefront of some very
interesting technological changes
in our world and culture.
Linux, open source, I spent time
at AWS, the internet and web, I've
just been around those.
I think we are at a similar
junction right now with AI.
I know I'm not unique in saying
that, but I believe that many
types of software and applications
are going to be fundamentally
restructured in how they're built,
and how they solve problems for
people using AI.
And so I look a lot of ways of
just how can we rethink a problem
and be able to solve it with AI.
I mean, my computer science
background comes out here a bit in
the sense that there are many
problems that are algorithmically
very hard.
Problems that we might
traditionally have said fall into
the NP complete path where they're
non-polynomial time solutions.
They're very complicated, and
they're hard, and they take a lot
of time to solve.
But we can now, using machine
learning, create some pretty good
approximations to solutions that
we couldn't in the past.
We can now do processing around We
can now do processing around
natural language that we couldn't
do in the past.
I'm super excited about the things
that we can do as a result of
that.
So those are some of the things,
some of the things that I think
about there.
You don't look back at your life
until now.
What are your proudest
achievements?
Oh, I will start with something we
haven't talked a lot about, but I
have a wonderful family.
My daughter is my proudest
achievement.
She studied computer engineering
and gaming, and theater, film, and
television.
So I'm just super proud as a dad.
On the sort of career side, I'm
proud that I've been able to help
some people create the things that
they've been able to do.
In many ways, I look back, and
I've said I'm something of a hack
when it comes to being able to
create things in code, and I'm
super proud that I think I've been
able to support and help some
people who are just brilliant that
have created some technology that
makes the world better for
everyone.
There's a little bit for you.
And is there anything if you had
your time again you would do
differently?
You know, it's hard to say
because, you know, as I look back
now, I realize how naive I was at
every stage, but that's how we
learn.
So I'm not big on the would have,
should have, could have done it
differently.
I think everyone has to go through
the learning phases, and there's a
ton of things that I got wrong all
the time.
There's a ton of, but I listened a
lot, and I hope I learned from
those, and I hope I don't, you
know, I hope I've learned along
the way, and that I get better,
and I can impart some of that
knowledge.
But I also believe people also
have to go through some of that.
So this is a little of my
philosophy when I advise
entrepreneurs and companies.
I give them advice, but I also
think they have to learn
themselves, and people make
mistakes.
That's part of the learning
process.
It's one of the things I think is
great about the Silicon Valley
culture is that it's a culture in
which people learn from making
mistakes, and you can make a
mistake, and get better, and
learn, and come back, and that's
okay.
So that's how I think about,
that's how I think about that
question.
So what's your relationship with
the community, you know, free and
open source community, like what's
your relationship with old
acquaintances like Dolman,
Torvalds, Mad Dog Hall?
I was on the Clinics Foundation
Board of Directors for a long
time.
I was an early person who helped
get that organization going.
I work with a lot of open source
entrepreneurs today.
I love that community.
I don't spend as much time online
as I used to.
Now there's more time for family
and other things in my life.
But I still spend a lot of time,
if you look at the angel investing
and places where I go, I spend a
lot of time with people there, and
it's just been fantastic and
lucky, and I've loved it.
Maybe we already covered this a
little bit because, you know, we
were talking about learning from,
you know, errors and mistakes that
one can go through, but what
advice would you give to someone
willing to pursue your career?
I would say a couple of things.
One is pursue things that you
love.
I think that's very important.
I have always made decisions for
me about doing things that I
personally thought were important
or loved or enjoyed or wanted to
be involved with.
Not because I thought I could make
money doing that, and I don't know
if that's great advice.
It's worked for me.
I'll just say that.
I have been lucky that it's left
me in a position where I can
continue to do more of that, and I
think there's something to that.
Pursuing things for passion, I
think, brings you a certain depth
to them that pursuing them just
for money doesn't, so I always
encourage that.
I always encourage learning.
You know, I go back to kind of my
early life where I told the story,
you know, you're in the field and
the tractor breaks.
I don't know anything about
tractors, but I can figure it out,
you know.
I'll try it.
What's the worst case?
It's broken already, you know.
Maybe I'll break it more, but
maybe I'll fix it, and by the way,
if I don't fix it, I don't know
who is, so it's okay to dive into
things that you don't know, and
maybe you'll learn something along
the way and improve things.
I really encourage people with
this.
I worry sometimes that our society
in some ways has become too
cautious around people, you know,
willing to just fix or figure out
or dive in and solve a problem,
and I encourage people.
You don't know.
You don't know how to do
something.
It's okay, you know, but by the
way, you'll probably make
mistakes, you know, figuring it
out, but don't let that stop you.
Try, learn, dive into things.
Many of the things I've done in my
career, I didn't know what I was
doing when I started, but things
I've done in my career, I didn't
know what I was doing when I
started, but I listened, I
learned, and ultimately,
ultimately, I helped create things
that were better, and I learned a
lot and educated a lot and
educated myself in that, so take
those risks.
Is there anything you would like
to add that we haven't covered
today?
This has been a great,
wide-ranging discussion, and I
want to thank you.
Okay, so thank you.
Thank you, Elisabetta.
And it's been a real pleasure
talking to you today.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.